hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book 10 of his confession saint
augustine discusses at significant
length the power of memory and one of
the things that he focuses on in one
particular chapter
is the emotions or as we can call them
following his own
verbiage the affections
of the human mind and there's some
paradoxical things that he notes when it
comes to these you know a lot of times
when we dredge something out of memory
we're bringing that thing before our you
know mental eyes or in our mind and
we're you know having it there to
scrutinize
when it comes to our emotions it doesn't
seem that that's actually
the case so
what are some examples of this well he
says that without emotion
i remember having felt that particular
emotion and he gives a number
of different examples of this he says
that the memory contains the affections
of my mind not in that manner in which
the mind has them at the time it
experiences them like being angry at the
time or sad but in a very different
manner
after the fashion in which the power of
memory retains memory itself without
actually being joyful
i remember myself to have been joyful
so i can
think about being joyful all i want
that's not necessarily going to make me
joyful or
without actually being sad i recall my
past sorrow without fear i recall that i
was at one time fearful without desire
i'm mindful of previous desires so this
is kind of strange isn't it that we can
bring our past emotions our experiences
of these
to light and yet we don't actually feel
them well it gets even better
sometimes we can feel the opposites or
at least a different sort of thing i can
feel a different emotion remembering an
emotion
he chooses opposites so he says that i
remember with joy my bygone
sorrow why would we remember with joy
our sorrow from the past well we think
well i should have been sad back then
and i'm not feeling that now so that
that's good right and he says with
sorrow i remember past joy why would
remembering past joy
make us sad well we might think well i
shouldn't have taken joy in stealing
those fruit or pick whatever other
example we want from augustine's life or
our own lives and we can think of all
sorts of emotions we could think of
feeling
fearful of our past emotions we could
think of being
angry that we felt something at the time
perhaps angry at others for making us
feel that perhaps angry at ourselves we
could feel all sorts of things hope
despair
um we could feel
you know an expression of surprise or
amazement that we felt something you
know looking back at it there's all
sorts of possible modalities what we're
not feeling is the emotion that is
under discussion the one that is coming
up and augustine gives us an analogy to
try to
explain it he says that well
maybe
memory is sort of like the mind's
stomach
you know the stomach is where we store
the food now of course we know
physiologically there's more things
going on it's breaking it down and all
of that but just go with with the
analogy for the time being we eat the
food we taste the food right and it goes
down our throat we have that feeling of
fullness and now the stomach is is full
if you want to say not necessarily
stomach but the whole digestive tract go
ahead
you're not tasting it while it's in your
belly right you're done tasting it as a
matter of fact that's why some people
are like well i need to eat some more
you know there's that old commercial
about uh i think i think it was lay's
potato chips you can't eat just one why
not because you ate the one and oh that
was so good and now it's down in my
stomach i'd like to have that experience
again let me have another potato chip
and then you find the whole bag is gone
after a while and your stomach is oh i
shouldn't eat so many potato chips it
doesn't feel good but it's not the
taste of it that's bothering you
it's the sensation of fullness
there's different things going on with a
stomach
and so augustine says you know maybe
joy and sadness are like sweet and
bitter food now why does he choose sweet
and bitter food well because in the
ancient
way of looking at flavors interestingly
enough
sweet is on one end and bitter is on the
other end of a spectrum you'll find
aristotle talking about this for example
in
onsens and the sensible and on the soul
and this is a very common way of looking
at flavors you know the bitter stuff
well that's kind of like sadness sweet
is kind of like joy we might associate
other emotions maybe fear is like the
salty
or anger is like the the uh sour you
know we could go on and on and on by the
way in ancient times it was common to
distinguish anywhere between seven to
nine flavors uh basic flavors of food
and so this is this is something that
his audience would be quite familiar
with
and so you know when you're chewing the
food you when you're having the
experience of the joy or the sadness you
are tasting it the sweetness or the
bitterness but then it goes down into
the stomach
and it's stored there and you don't
taste it anymore so the memory like the
stomach
doesn't have a sense of taste he says
when they are committed to memory they
are as it were passed into the stomach
and they can be stored there but they
cannot be tasted
so
okay that kind of works and then he's
got a little conjecture later on maybe
remembering
is like rumination
and this notion of
remembering or recalling recollection
being like ruminating is is actually
going to be quite a
important metaphor
for understanding texts uh from
augustine onward now when we say
ruminating we're talking about something
that we human beings don't typically do
with our food
ruminating creatures are those that have
multiple stomachs so the food gets
chewed it goes down into the first
stomach and then it gets spit back up
into the the mouth and then it's chewed
some more then it goes into the next
stomach think about cows for example
right or deer
those are ruminating creatures so the
act of recollection
is like rumination it can bring the
thing back up but it's not coming back
up in exactly the same state and we can
either feel nothing about it or we can
feel
perhaps even an opposite emotion
now he goes into a discussion that i
think requires a little bit of
clarification
in this where he's using some examples
and the examples that he's using these
four
passions or perturbations
of the mind
this is coming from the stoics a
philosophical school that was very
popular in antiquity that augustine knew
quite well the stoics had a theory of
the emotions that broke it down
into
four basic
classes of emotions and all of the
different emotions fit into those four
buckets in one way or another now
augustine himself is not a stoic he
actually
thinks that the stoics are a little bit
wrong
in condemning a lot of emotions when we
have to be a little bit more nuanced but
what he's talking about here
is sort of a commonplace
of how emotions are
understood so he talks about desire
cupiditas right the desire for something
the yearning for something
opposed to that would be fear right
mehtum
and fear can take a whole bunch of
modalities as well desires towards fear
is a way and the stoics would actually
say
that desire and fear are for what is not
yet present
desire steers you towards the good that
you perceive
that you want and fear makes you go away
from the evil that you perceive then
there's joy like titia
and sadness tritsitzia
and those are for present good or evil
at least perceived good or evil
is this exactly the way the stoics uh
articulate it no sometimes they talk
instead of just desire and fear and joy
and sadness instead about pleasure and
pain you know like voluptas rather than
lititzia right
dolum
rather than tristitia but it's it's more
or less the same sort of thing that
augustine has in mind and he notes that
all of these can be discussed or
analyzed even argued about without
feeling these emotions so he's using
this stoic classification
as an example of something that we can
go into discussion about and think about
it right here
we've been talking about emotion
emotions that you yourself feel
and have felt in the past that are going
to keep on feeling and did talking about
this did talking about joy
make you remember
joy think back to something that you
felt joyful about it doesn't necessarily
make you feel joyful now
does going into
psychological discussion
about these things make you feel those
no
so there's something quite interesting
again even paradoxical
about the way in which memory
can deal with
or bring to bear
emotions that we have felt in the past
or
even the very ideas
that we've learned about emotions say
from the stoics
so there's a lot of interesting stuff
packed just into this one chapter this
one consideration about what memory does
you